[Applause]
please welcome espn's rachel nichols
thanks so much what a game guys what a
way to close
now before we give out the eastern
conference trophy i do want to take a
minute
to recognize the boston celtics let's
give them a round of applause
showing throughout this playoff run they
are most
one of the most talent rich teams in the
league they are going to be a threat in
this conference
for years to come kudos to them
all right let's give out this trophy i
want to recognize
up in the glass box over there team
owner
mickey erison president pat riley
gm andy ellsberg the architects
of this group behind me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey coach eric spoelstra please come get
your shiny ball trophy here
[Applause]
a socially distance what can i tell you
eric i have covered all three of your
championship
runs first with the dwyane wade shack
and then two of course with dwayne and
lebron
i'm not sure i've ever seen you coach a
group that is more heat culture
than these guys here what do they
represent to you
uh well obviously first you mentioned it
we want to uh tip our hat to the boston
celtics uh this is a hell of a series
and
it was great competition um
and yes you you stole it from us but can
we do some rapid testing or something
and get our crew down here to the
harrisons to the godfather
yeah coach chris uh i know
zoe you're probably up there scowling at
us shane
dwayne i know you're out there watching
somewhere cb
he nation uh but
it's this group right here obviously uh
this group uh
more than anything they just love to
compete uh we're so grateful for this
opportunity in this bubble
this group would have done it in an
empty gym with nobody watching
uh just toss that ball up and i just
i love the fact that this group is so
pure and they enjoy each other's success
it's a special group
this is of course the organization's
first trip back to the finals since
2014.
you had a player then by the name of
lebron james you will now be facing him
in the nba finals what is that going to
be like i mean
that's a great storyline right can you
let us enjoy this for a little bit right
now
this is hard to do it's hard to get to
this
this point um and i want our guys to
recognize that acknowledge it enjoy it
uh for at least a night and then we'll
get on to uh that
uh tomorrow we'll give you that tonight
the finals don't start till wednesday
thank you so much coach
let's get jimmy butler up here
[Applause]
jimmy you told me before the playoffs
started
you said oh this team this team can win
an nba championship
this year well you're almost there you
made it to the nba finals are you still
just that confident
very much so uh i think coach pat and
everybody else in the organization did a
great job of putting this group together
um we've been together we've been in
each other's corner
all year long and it doesn't stop here
we got four more to go
what a journey for you personally not
really recruited out of high school
junior college kid and then of course to
marquette
last pick in the first round when you
were drafted success with the bulls but
they did not choose to hang on to you
and i'm not
even going to get into what happened in
minnesota jimmy but you found your
family your basketball
family here with the heat considering
where you started
what does it mean for you to reach in
nba finals it means everything this is
why we all play to win it we've talked
about it all year long we stayed
confident
through injuries the ups and downs we
always stay together we will continue to
play together
we'll do this as a team like i said four
more to go
but if a group can do it we could do it
confident as
always thank you so much jimmy butler
let's bring bam out
[Applause]
you said that this team's game five loss
was your fault you said that you played
quote terrible what did you want to come
out here tonight and do to make up for
that
uh and i just uh
just had to get locked in you know i
couldn't let my teammates down like i
did in the game before so
you know i just went out there and just
tried to execute make plays and i did
that tonight
you are the product of a mother who did
everything for you worked multiple jobs
didn't have a car so she walked to those
jobs
you still keep a picture of the single
wide trailer
that you grew up in with you and your
mom said she would come down here to
orlando
if you made it to the nba finals well
you made it bam
what do you have to say to her uh she'll
be up here
tuesday um you know like i always say
man that's my rock that's my chip
that's who i do it for you know it's my
pride and joy you know you guys will be
the underdogs your number five seed
playing against the number one seeded
lakers and lebron james
what do you think of your chances what
kind of battle will it be
man we've been underdogs our whole life
everybody up here got a chip on their
shoulder from something so man
it's a toss-up we're getting the finals
you know we
we're not backing down from anybody and
that's what i like about this team
well congratulations to you i know that
trophy is going to get a lot of love
tonight
congratulations to all you guys you
earned this one
the hard way headed to the nba finals
your eastern conference champion miami
back up to you mike
thank you rachel well they started the
playoffs with a sweep of a very good
indiana team
and then the milwaukee bucks the best
record in the nba all
season they eliminated them in five
games
and now the boston celtics in six games
eric spoelstra bam adebayo the entire
team
just continue this incredible run
through these 20 20
bubble playoffs and now a chance to play
for the nba championship starting on
wednesday night
against the los angeles lakers and it
really is a terrific team they've got a
lot of individual talent
but they play so well together so well
connected
at both ends of the floor and they'll
celebrate for sure tonight
here on the bubble and then get back to
work fairly quickly to try and plan
against the lakers who of course
eliminated the denver nuggets last night
in the western conference finals
bam out of bio what a performance from
him
in as big a game as he's played in his
in his brief nba career he's only 23 in
his third year
this year he makes his first all-star
team this year he makes all nba defense
and now he's going to the nba finals we
talk about young stars he is one of the
mark
well took the challenge and owned up to
the fact that he didn't play up the paw
and dominated this game on both sides of
the floor was truly a present
attacking the paint all night long coach
i mean the ability to
go off the dribble finish at the basket
a mid-range game
make his free throws and then pass like
this makes him special
he was spectacular and they ran through
him
and it wasn't just about his scoring his
play-making ability separated him
and made him the best player on the
floor
and again that 32 points the most he's
ever scored plus the rebounding the
defense
a little bit of everything now you know
all season long
this miami team everybody said hey
they're a good team
and the phrase you always heard they're
going to be a tough out in the playoffs
but i don't think very many people
outside of the miami heat locker room
thought that they could get to the nba
finals jeff
no because you had to pass through so
many good teams indiana in the first
round
obviously they had some injuries but to
sweep them
but the the stunner to me was the
milwaukee series
mark where they really dominated that
series from start to finish
well you get a bunch of guys that's
willing to compete willing to
willing to fight unselfish and you don't
have to beg for energy and effort and
enthusiasm
anything is possible and this team has a
legitimate chance even though they'll be
underdogs
they have a legitimate chance you'd be a
fool to count them out all right what's
what would you think
again it's quick to turn it around for
everybody but what do you think are the
keys for miami
to to not only compete against the
lakers but to win
well they've got to keep them in half
court like the lakers are devastating
because of their defense which turns
into transition offense
they're guardable in half court they
don't have a lot of weapons i'll be
interested to see
what they can do with davis how they
match up do they double do they play
their zone a lot i'm just interested in
the whole thing but
you're right i don't think you can
discount what miami
is going to be capable of in the finals
and the zone is effective and i believe
it'll be effective against this laker
team that doesn't have
the same type of shooting so to be very
interesting how eric supposed to design
a defense to contain that lake offense
and as we all know it's all different
here in the nba bubble these 20 20
playoffs
unprecedented circumstances miami taking
full advantage remember they have the
fifth best record in the east
but here they are representing the
eastern conference
in the nba finals so again it'll all
start on wednesday night
andre iguodala going to his sixth
consecutive finals
a great mixture of some savvy veterans
and terrific young players miami heat
defeat the boston celtics in the eastern
conference finals in six games
they will advance and play the lakers
starting wednesday night we'll have it
for you on abc
right now let's go back to sportscenter